[Music]
2016 was again the hottest year on
record and the previous 17 years have
been our 16 most scorching scientists
overwhelmingly agree global warming is
the culprit and the carnage is just
getting started
ice max extreme weather wildfires
droughts and the hits keep coming what
are we doing about it
in 2015 the world took its boldest step
yet to stem climate change with a
historic Accord in Paris but now comes
the hard part
nations must change energy policies and
invest huge amounts of money and they
may be doing it without the United
States the world's richest nation and
second biggest polluter I am taken
historic steps to lift the restrictions
on American energy to reverse government
intrusion and to cancel job-killing
regulations 68 days into his new
administration President Trump signed an
executive order that stopped just short
of withdrawing from the Paris agreement
here's the situation decades in the
making the Paris agreement United the
u.s. China and more than 190 other
nations in a push to limit fossil fuel
pollution the UN sponsored plan secured
pledges to cut greenhouse gases the
emissions that trap heat in the Earth's
atmosphere in an effort to avoid the
rising seas and other environmental
disasters the climate models prevail but
even if all pledges are met the globe is
expected to warm by as much as three
point four degrees Celsius this century
more than the UN target of well below
two degrees
governments will have to offer more
incentives for clean energy scale back
support for fossil fuels make emissions
more costly and reduce deforestation
it's estimated that the deal will
require thirteen point five trillion
dollars of spending through 2030 here's
the argument unlike past climate pacts
such as the Kyoto Protocol each
countries set its own Paris targets and
then promised to revisit and improve the
US was primed to play a lead role in
climate change but Trump's energy
independence executive order reverses
Obama era rules and encourages increased
production of coal the dirtiest fossil
fuel my administration is putting an end
to the war on coal and have clean coal
really clean coal the resulting policies
make it very hard for the u.s. to keep
its commitment to ignitions reduction
even if Trump decides to pull out of the
Accord the Paris agreement would live on
businesses cities and US states such as
California are already investing in wind
and solar and taking other steps to make
it work I've actually been called an
environmentalist if you can believe that
[Music]